to some extent this has always been the
case like there's always been YouTubers
who have really big audiences and those
audiences don't translate to people who
would show up for an event or by merch
or support them another thing just
because like they're more into the thing
they make than the person themselves
but this is definitely more of a thing
on Tick Tock and I think a big part of
it is that you don't choose what to
watch so you have to sort of like be fed
their content and you aren't fed their
content unless it's extremely popular so
the stuff that is like a little bit just
like a little bit less engaging because
they're talking about a live show
they're doing or because they're talking
about themselves rather than their
content rather than like some epic story
or some really good like you can do it
on Tick Tock I've seen people do it but
it's a lot harder and I think that that
is a function of the fact that every
view is algorithmic and there's no human
choice that goes into what I actually
want to watch versus what I want to keep
watching also I didn't know this was a
thing until this moment